Es ist soweit der deutsche astronaut alexander gerst hat sich heute mittwoch den. 6 juni. Zusammen mit zwei weiteren
Kollegen auf dem weg zur raumstation iss gemacht zur
internationalen raumstation
Eines der meist gewünschten dem die, er mir hier über whatsapp. Geschickt habt ist die frage warum die ss
Überhaupt sichtbar ist die erklärung dazu gibt es jetzt auf einem noch, ein. Paar tipps und tricks
Um die iss zu beobachten und zu fotografieren herzlich willkommen bei pixum science and fiction und vielen dank für den artikel vorschlag
Ja viele von euch wissen es sicher die iss kann, man, unter ganz bestimmten bedingungen tatsächlich
mit dem bloßen auge erkennen ganz
Ohne teleskop dabei ist sie rund 400 kilometer von der erde entfernt doch mit ihrem solarpanels ist sie in etwa
So groß wie ein ganzes fußballfeld. Und
dementsprechend im fussball 90 minuten braucht die station also eine spiellänge, um mit
28.800
Stundenkilometern die erde einmal zu umrunden für die astronauten und astronauten die auf ihr leben und arbeiten bedeutet das dass sie pro tag
sonnenauf und untergänge zu sehen bekommen alexander gerst soll übrigens
187 tage auf der iss arbeiten und leben und am mittwoch, um 13, uhr 12, mitteleuropäischer
Zeit geht es oder ist es für ihn an bord. Einer sojus rakete vom kasachischen weltraumbahnhof baikonur
Gegangen mit dabei, ein, ehemaliger kampfpilot aus russland und eine amerikanische medizinerinnen
Und ingenieurin der flug zur iss soll zwei tage dauern doch wie können wir hier von der erde die station verfolgen die
109 meter spannweite der station
Reflektieren das sonnenlicht. Und richtig gut zu erkennen ist sie nur morgens oder abends
Und zwar wenn sie, sich weder im erdschatten noch auf der anderen seite der erde befindet
Dann, sieht sie aus wie ein heller stern am himmel der lautlos über ihn hinweg zieht. Und zwar innerhalb weniger minuten die station wird
Dann, vom sonnenlicht angestrahlt doch der himmel ist in der dämmerung. Noch oder schon dunkel die esa
hat einen trecker auf ihrer webseite der genau zeigt
Wo sich die station gerade befindet darunter ist auch direkt die stelle auf der erde zu sehen über den sie
Sich gerade befindet wenn nachts keine wolken am himmel sind ist die raumstation von dieser stelle aus mit bloßem auge zu sehen auch
ihre genaue
Flugroute also aus welcher richtung sie kommt über welche orte sie fliegt und wie lange sie sichtbar ist dazu gibt es im internet viele
Verschiedene seiten eine empfehlung bekommt er von mir. Und zwar zu der folgenden seite der nasa
Gps
doppelpunkt
Spots ist ation dort nasa dot com
ja
Und was doppelpunkt auf englisch heißt das schreibt, er mehr in die kommentare hier könnt ihr einfach
Eine größere stadt in eurer nähe angeben und schon durch angezeigt an welchem tag, und zu welcher uhrzeit
Ihr die iss am besten sehen können zudem gibt es infos dazu ob sie eher flach am horizont fliegt oder aber
Steil am himmel entlang merken könnt. Ihr? Euch jedenfalls schon. Mal dass sie es immer aus der westlichen richtungen kommt also daher
Wo die sonne untergegangen ist wenn
Er sie beobachten volt machte sinn, einen möglichst dunklen stand auch. Zu wählen wenn andere lichtquellen wie straßenlaternen
Könnten, euch stören, kombat zum fotografieren. Einfach auf den auslöser drücken reicht hier leider nicht denn. Dann habt. Ihr nachher bloß
Einen kleinen hellen punkt auf den auf dunklem hintergrund welt deswegen eine längere
Belichtungszeit aus beispielsweise eine minute lang. Und dann könnt. Ihr euch verdenken vielleicht denken was passiert. Dann habt
Ihr mich quasi eine leuchtspur am himmel festgehalten. Und richtig cool kann das foto dann werden wenn
Ihr euch noch, einen weiteren schönen hingucker für den
Forderungen organisierten baumhaus dächer oder spitzen kirchturm andersherum geht das ganze übrigens auch wenn
er also bock habt von der iss die erde zu sehen klickt
Euch mal rum im netz denn tatsächlich sendet sie bilder live. Zur erde. Manchmal kann man. Dabei sogar den
Astronauten bei der arbeit zugucken außerdem gibt es auch die möglichkeit den funk sprich verkehr mit den
Kontrollzentren auf der erde mit anzuhören wenn. Ihr kein video zur raumfahrt
Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp nur dann verpasst
Ihr kein video denn die abo box auf youtube.de ist ja mal. Ein bisschen glück in haft über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
Noch vor allen andern vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Ihr kriegt also vorher eine meldung. Und zur begrüßung habe ich noch
Ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten. Auch meinen schwesterkanal kriegs, um, social and media abonnieren das geht hier erfahrt
Ihr das neueste aus der social media welt aber nicht die
Genau, die glocken vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken felton harry die revolution der raumfahrt bis dann würde ich mal sagen
bleibt dran